[Music]
thank you thank everyone well there's
one thing I've learned working with my
team that I would like to share and that
I will I will never forget is that we
know that writing fast applications
makes our users and our customers happy
so who doesn't want to write fast code
raise your hand that's interesting so
before we start I have a couple of
questions that I need to ask and then
I'll see what the internet tells us so
the first question is if you go on your
favorite web browser and your favorite
search engine a new type is JavaScript
fast how fast is JavaScript probably get
something like this that says and I'm
just quoting under the right
circumstances it is very fast actually
as fast as C if you search again another
result would be why is it so fast it is
because as soon as you understand the
event loop and now it processes requests
you realize it's so fast you start to
see a pattern like fast is because it's
fast and you keep going on and you get
stuff like how can it be so fast since
it's a single thread and the answer like
in this example is because it's
lightweight we keep going and and then
you find this interesting question how
fast is it compared to Java but because
most recruiters think that Java and
JavaScript are the same thing which is
kind of interesting so if you look
around and on the internet you see stuff
like Jay s is awesome and hot and shines
when it comes to a huge amount of short
connections and finally because well it
could be all day showing a
Google result results but what does it
make faster than Java well and the
answer is because the sync ecosystem is
more than 50 thousand modules written in
a synchronous style it's kind of strange
answer to the question but giving all
these questions we need to ask do we
trust the internet like the internet is
full of stories and like some Game of
Thrones characters said a few weeks ago
stories connect people
however stories are not exact science
and above all they they should not drive
us as a software engineer so my
interpretation is do I trust Internet no
I don't and why because I am a software
engineer as you can if you don't know
what who invented who coined the term
you can go on our exhibition hall and
there's explanation err who who did it
and you see that if you look on
dictionary for software engineering says
engineer the is the application of
Science and Mathematics by which the
properties of matter and the sources of
energy in nature are made useful to
people so as a software engineer we
should apply science and mathematics to
the way out to solve our problems so
going back to the question is JavaScript
fast we need we must be able to
reproduce the problem we must be able to
explain the results and reproduce the
results so I think the right answer is
is JavaScript fast
I don't know from these results it's
it's not clear so starting now with a
main topic like when I was planning the
talk I needed a title so I end up with
10 things I learned making the fastest
JavaScript server runtime in the world
so I carefully decided to pick the word
server because again going to Wikipedia
for definition a server is a computer in
a network that users
that is used to provide services to
other computers in the network so what
I'm gonna what I am about to tell you is
not about command line applications or
lambdas
it's about long-running processors so we
need to also define what is fast so
because when I say fast I don't mean
that I'm fast because I put my server on
a racecar and put a car running around
now it's but when I mean by fast is that
we need to agree in a common set of
metrics and for this I'm using what the
site reliability engineering as as found
out so if you don't know anything about
such reliability engineering there's
this interesting link with a nice books
from Google and Google as one of the
biggest teams on oh sorry
and nursery has identified five gold
golden signals so golden signals are
critical to the monitoring teams to
monitor their systems and inta fie
problems before they become really a big
problem so there are many metrics to
monitor but this team this team does a
sorry team show that rate errors and
latency saturation novelisation contain
virtually all the information you need
to know about what's going on and where
so getting these signals is quite
challenging and varietals and the
services uuuu you have on your disposal
but for now I'm just considering rate as
in requests per second air is like in
airs per second of course and latency is
in response time including waiting and
queuing so focusing on rate errors and
latency means that I will focus on the
software are not going to be focusing on
the hardware or in the operating system
so a typical server application as a
well set well known set of
characteristics we need to know our the
application behaves and only once we
understand that we can
talk about it so what is a server
application so my definition of sir
application is a long-running process it
should be deployed on a cloud or in bare
metal and it should be attached to a
phase Network otherwise network becomes
your bottleneck and of course should
have enough CPU and memory so your
application is not constrained by by
your hardware so along running processes
has different characteristics from a
short running process of course so in a
long-running process the startup and
warming up is not really real relevant
in the full span lifecycle of the server
because it's a very tiny moment again
this isn't true if you're talking about
web applications on your browser because
you want to be as fast as possible
because that's what drives the happiness
of your users so now we need to define
how to measure things ought to mention
work benchmark things so most internet
articles will tell you how fast
something is but most of the time when
you read the whole article you see some
graphs really nice graphs but the
information about how the tests were
performed and all the results were
obtained is emitted so from us
engineering perspective this is
incorrect we should be able to reproduce
the test and the results in a lab that
gives you more or less or exactly the
same results of course on top of that
the experiment should be reviewed
because we need to confirm that the
results are not biased so when I write a
benchmark I don't want to I don't want
to to make it be my friend and enemy of
the other side it needs to be fair
writing benchmarks of course is hard
because first every benchmark you write
will never rip represent a real-world
use case it's always like a tiny subset
that doesn't really represent your
plication so you need to get into
conclusions from just looking at a tiny
bit of your lifecycle so getting peer be
to review your code can be really hard
to find and getting peers to tensed
against and are that are willing to
review what you wrote is even harder so
what I'm trying to tell is that
benchmarking is hard and however there
is a very popular benchmark out there
that is called the tech and power
frameworks benchmark why is this
benchmark so interesting to me well to
me it's like taking power benchmark it
shows you the true nature of open source
it has more than 500 contributors so
more than 500 different people have
contributed tests and reviewed the tests
there are more than 3,000 merged pull
requests so lots of people spend time
reviewing or having new tests so to the
framework and they already have more
than 10,000 commits so it shows that
it's kind of a big big project it's not
something that someone just planned in
in the weekend I wanna check out my
framework works now it's something that
has been growing steadily for a last
couple of years and it already tests
more than 630 different frameworks and
these frameworks are written different
different languages so this makes the my
life easier because I don't need to
invent my own benchmark I don't need to
explain it I can just use it to to prove
what I want to say so if you want to
have the the link this is like their
github repo and from the github repo you
can get to the main website of course
and as I said there are like six and
thirty different frameworks so if I
would try to print on the screen how it
looks right now
well it wouldn't fit on this screen so
what I did I just rotated my screen I
took a screen shot and don't worry about
the size it's not really relevant what
I'm trying to say is that there are lots
of frameworks that are already been
tested and the quick question I want to
ask the audience is like can you spot
the best result for the JavaScript
framework on this graph so probably
cannot because it's very small so I have
here helper you'll find that as shocking
as it can be the first entry for
JavaScript ranks at number 89 which
performs at about twenty two point seven
percent of the performance of the best
result so if you look at this I think
well we all have this idea that
javascript is fast and what results
prove proof prove things wrong that it's
not as fast as we think it is so what we
need to do is that we need to look under
the hood so before we can do any
optimization we need to understand
what's going on and we shouldn't jump
into conclusions and start tweaking the
code of the benchmark because otherwise
we are just yak shaving in not really
looking into the problem you're just
trying to mitigate what what could be
the cause so instead of this we need to
take a scientific approach and if you
haven't learned anything about profiling
and note applications I would recommend
you to look at the very good tutorial on
an OGS website on on profiling so just
to give you like a in a nutshell
information from the from this tutorial
if you look at one of the tests of the
of the benchmark which is very simple
return an ello world string from an HTTP
server the best result that you could
read that you saw on the benchmark was
implemented like this so it uses the
cluster module the cluster module will
fork the node process for
number of CPUs that the environment has
and then it uses an express server to
set the content type and send the
response okay probably the Express is
not the most performance library out
there but it this is just for
illustration so once we do this and we
do profiling we get a flame graph so
flame graphs are really interesting to
when you're talking about performance
because they give like a visual
explanation on where your CPU time is
spent the the width of the of the bars
or the coloring doesn't really matter
the coloring is just to give it like to
make it nice and it's called frame
graphs because usually we paint it from
red to yellow like a flame but what what
is important to notice is here as you go
from bottom up you you you see where the
code is spending most time on on your
CPU so if you observe this you basically
what the flame graph is telling you is
that there is a very tiny piece on the
top where where the JavaScript code is
being spent on and then there's lots of
time where it's spend on native and
native means there the note bindings v8
lib movie for the sync i/o and live
video so for the event loop so so once
you start trying to optimize this the
code we we end up like trying to
optimize just the tip of the iceberg
you cannot optimize everything because
most of the time and if I would go back
most of the time here is spend on on
native code so you just optimizing the
tip of the iceberg so this makes you
think right like this is interesting
what can we do about this so if you
ask yourself what is the first thing
that comes on on your mind when I say
Java scan engine I think most of you
will say v8 so if you look at the
mission statement of the v8 project it
reads something like speed up real-world
performance for more than JavaScript and
enable developers to build a faster
future web so the performance of v8 is
great but there are more engines out
there so if you look at the Ganga stable
which is not an authority on JavaScript
engines it just lists the compatibility
of es6 across many there you can see
engines like chakracore spider monkey
Safari and there's a late a new one that
was a edit like last year called grudges
so what my experiment was all about is
that well I should try other engines
because if most of the CPU we spend on
native part probably I should look into
engines that handle this JavaScript
runtime in a different way so I decided
to look into garage yes so grudges and
is an extension of the Java util machine
that supports more languages and
execution models so the group project
includes a new high performance compiler
itself called growl because as you know
the most difficult thing in computer
science in science is naming things so
you call it also ground because it's
interesting and the objective of growl
is to improve the performance of the
vehicle machine on any language and
another goal is to allow freeform mixing
of any programming language in a single
program so allows you to do polyglot
programming so on the same program you
can use Java Scala groovy JavaScript
Ruby roast Python C C++ and what's
interesting about this is that because
it's a new project and it's all up to
date they offer a modern JavaScript
runtime based on ES 2019 years 2020
which isn't release yet
but they already implemented with most
of the features and my ultimate goal is
to a very fast server but I don't want
to change my programming language
language I want to stay on JavaScript so
if I look at the definition of broad GS
on their website their goals are to ask
you javascript code with the best
possible performance a full support for
the latest yes
specification and fast interoperability
with all the languages on either on on
the JVM or other language supported by
Gras like Ruby Python and are there
there are a lot of academic research
around this because this project all
although it was open sourced last year
it's been running for more than eight
years behind closed doors it's just been
open now because now they feel that it's
like in a real stable mature project so
the people working and researching on
this I have already shown that the
engine is slightly better or on par with
v8 for just pure language benchmarks and
you can read more about the paper there
so and although you can even run like
unmodified node applications on it
because it allows you to just replace v8
from from node I need to formulate
hypotheses what if we create a project
that I would call Atma script for X that
first will replace v8 with garage yes
second will replace libuv with Eclipse
vertex will replace the v8 and
just-in-time compiler with a growl
compiler will not you have node bindings
it will just use typescript definitions
because this can be discarded at runtime
so the code that you don't run is the
best code because it's the fastest you
don't need to run it of course anyway to
offer you a basic common GS and yes
module loader as some basic NPM
compatibility and allows you to even
develop profile application with the
tools you already know like the chrome
dev tools so if if we were going to
implement the the previous example that
I showed which with node and Express
using this new style this is how the the
old Express code would will look like so
I guess it's not that hard to understand
what's happening here the important
thing here to notice is that the the
library I chose vertex by default uses
all the available cores and your machine
so you don't need to use a close to
module to the forks so this is all
handled behind the scenes for you and
vertex provides and provides us and
optimize the sink ILP I build on top of
net leonetti is open source project that
is used by big names like Google Twitter
Netflix just to name a few so if you
want to test this first thing is that
well you need to install a very simple
application called yes for X p.m. like
short for project manager because we
cannot run no directly need to run
through yes for X so if I had to show
you this is how it looks I created a
project I can make it like with a new
module syntax and I recorded this so
because I'm afraid that I wouldn't have
enough time so you just have a couple of
dependencies this is pure NPN NPM stuff
I just use vertex and we're because I
want to do a replication so I create and
you can even do like the es6 modules
exports I can say okay my homepage is a
function that I will export that will
just say hello hello from vertex plus
yes Forex and of course now I need to
bootstrap a server so I create the index
which is like my main application and
again is just import some code from the
vertex library I now import my route
from the the module I just created from
routes I know I just put strapped
bootstrap my my application so I create
the router but it's kind of the same
idea as the Express server so I now
create a router a route on on home and I
just passed my I call back and now I
create the server I specify who will
handle my server requests will be my
router and now I start listening on port
8080 and I hope so message so I'm
pruning yes so now I can just install
well I starting to mix NPM and yarn well
doesn't really matter so there are a
couple of utilities like I can quickly
get all my application running on on vs
code see it's already debugging I can
put a breakpoints and if I put a
breakpoint and if I now make an HTTP
request you see that the request is
there stopped and what's interesting you
to see is that due to the nature of
gravity M you can mix and see on the
debugger both your the code that comes
from the Java side and the code that you
wrote so everything is optimized so the
expectation is that once you write code
in this way in your user code plus your
runtime plus your Interop plus your
engine plus your io libraries plus the
old world that runs your application in
this case the the growl JDK it will all
be optimized by ground not just the
script itself
you're not optimizing just a tip of
the the iceberg optimizing everything so
to test the experiment several months
ago I submitted to the tech empower and
implementation of the benchmark using
this project and after being reviewed it
got accepted and this is how things are
so this is like the the the CI builds
you see that now es 4x is running is
ranking on number 5 which brings a
JavaScript from number 86 if I'm not
mistaken to number 5 in a simple
database query test that goes on the
post-race and gets results and ranked
number 6 when doing multiple query so
you see the parallel loading and testing
so if I have to compare now this
experiment with with all the frameworks
that were already on the benchmark this
is how it compares so when working with
a JSON well we see that the results give
you like 2 times better results than the
previous best result when going on a
post press database doing one query it's
three and a half times better but if you
have to be fair testing to the best
previous one that was running on post
press it's six times better doing
multiple queries so it means like
there's lots of concurrency going on
it's still two and a half times better
than the previous one and if we're doing
like data updates where the concurrency
is really the issue you see it's like
five times best better than the previous
one so to put this in numbers if you
think about request response you see
that is better of course I'm not talking
about a very small improvements tiny
improvements I'm talking about huge
numbers so the final tip is that
optimization is like a never-ending job
so for example we could get better
results if we use an enterprise edition
of draw instead of the open source
edition and that that gives you like 20%
better performance and because it's it's
optimization it's a never-ending job you
need to rain
repeat in any just like that so the key
points I want to give is that there's
nothing wrong with a javascript
javascript can be fast and probably you
don't need to switch to go rest whatever
because you're having a performance
issues you can still if you dare to
experiment you can still remain on on
JavaScript so if you want to learn more
you can either find me on Twitter get up
check the source code on on on github
and if there are any questions you can
catch me later thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]